- Mm-hmm. All right.
Hey, palsies!
My name is Cody,
and I'm a Helpster.
That means a monster who helps.
And because I love, love, love
to help so much,
I'm making these videos called...
One of my favorite things
is to have friends over and play games.
But guess what?
You can play games with friends
when they're far away, too.
Like right now, I'm going to
play a game with my friend...
- Ta-da!
- Amazing Alie!
- Cody, it is amazing to see you.
- Aw! I knew you were gonna say that.
Hey, Alie, please tell these
fabulous people what we're playing today.
- The game is called "scavenger hunt."
The way that it works is Cody
will ask me to find something.
- Yeah, and then Alie
asks me to find something.
Oh, oh, oh, and we have to use
directional words when we find our stuff.
- Like "on" or "under."
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, or--
or "next to" or "between."
Okay. You ready to play, Alie?
- So ready.
- Great! Okay.
So, Amazing Alie,
can you find something...
green? Hmm?
- Oh! Next to my chair is...
this plant.
- Oh! Alie, that is the greenest plant
I have ever seen.
You are amazing in every way.
Fantastic!
- Thank you, thank you, thank you.
- Oh, you are very welcome,
Amazing Alie.
Okay, uh, so, so you got--
you got one for me?
- Oh, you ready for this?
Cody, can you find something
made of wood?
- Hmm. Made of wood, huh?
Let's see, uh...
Oh. I got a good one for you.
Under my elephant is...
this wooden spoon!
Huh? What do you think?
- Amazing!
- Nice.
- Oh, wait a second.
Did you say it was under an elephant?
- Oh, yeah.
Yeah, under my elephant Lulu.
(elephant trumpets)
- Whoa.
- Yeah, she'd come over and say hello,
but right now
she's balancing on top of Julian.
He's a rhinoceros.
(elephant trumpets)
And they're both
inside a rocket ship.
'Cause they're about to
go into space. Oop!
- Have fun, you two!
- (elephant trumpets, rockets roar)
- Sounds like a busy day
at the shop.
- Eh, not really.
Well, anyway,
that's how you play scavenger hunt.
- And now you can play
with your friends and family,
or you can create
a new amazing game.
- Yeah, you can.
Well, that's it for today,
but I'll be back soon.
- Until then, make sure to help family,
friends, and monsters wherever you can.
- Yeah.
'Cause everyone loves a helping hand.
- Bye, Alie!
- Bye, Cody!
- Thanks so much
for playing with me today.